- All right, welcome to MAM339,
where we'll be diving into
Tipalti's transformation
to Windows containers on AWS.
I'm joined here today
by Maya Morav Freiman,
technical account manager with AWS,
who was part of the journey,
and lead DevOps architect
for Tipalti, Danny Teller,
who joins us today to give us
his experience and insights
on that journey.
And quick question
before we kick off today
to make sure these headphones are working,
who here is actually running
Windows applications,
Windows workloads and their environments?
Now, Windows containers?
All right, perfect.
How many have actually considered
containerizing these applications?
All right so, this is
gonna be a great session
because Danny has quite the
roadmap coming up here for you
where you'll be able to see
all the pitfalls and successes
that they've engaged over the
last 12 months doing this.
So our quick agenda for today,
we're gonna do a quick
background level set
on what containers are.
Then we're gonna dive into
Tipalti, their journey,
how they got where they are today,
the lessons learned, and what's next,
what happens after this.
And Danny, if you wanna
let the audience know
what they'll be in for
over the next 60 minutes,
that'd be perfect.
- Definitely. Thank you, Aidan.
So what we're gonna do today
is we're gonna walk through
from ancient to modern,
all the technical decision-making
that we had to go through,
the challenges we faced,
and our performance gains, optimizations,
all these fun stuff,
some truly weird things, and our results,
and finally how it impacted our business.
So stay in tuned, fellas.
Thank you, Aidan.
- Thank you.
So we'll see you in a few minutes.
So like I mentioned, we
just wanna level set.
So everybody's familiar with
what Windows containers are,
how they come around, and that way,
if you're an advanced
user or just beginning up,
you'll see how easy it is
to get started with them.
So we're all pretty
much familiar with this.
Back in the day,
one app per server wasn't a
great use of the hardware,
a lot of high costs,
wasn't very, very efficient at all.
Next up, as we all know, hypervisors.
It virtualized the operating system,
the hardware, which is great,
but unfortunately it still
wasn't that efficient.
You could only run so many
hypervisors in one box
and costs again are a major component.
Lastly, this is where containers
really come into its own,
virtualizing the operating system.
The benefit this has, you
can now have a shared kernel,
multiple containers using it,
and really optimizing your costs on this.
So big takeaway here is your cost,
your ability to spin up
new systems, be agile,
and just to be much more efficient
in the use of all these resources.
So a lot of people forget
that the first Docker spec
was created about 10 years ago, in 2015.
So it's a pretty solid
solution to go with today.
It's not like it's brand new.
I know people are familiar
with Linux containers,
that's what everybody thinks.
But fast forward to 2017,
that's when Microsoft enabled
Linux support on containers
that opened up hybrid strategies.
Again, we won't go
through every single item,
but containerd came up with Server 2019,
2023 Karpenter support enabled,
Amazon supported at the same time,
and it's continued to evolve today.
So the big takeaway here
is that 10 years later,
this is still an evolving process,
but it is really a tried and true method
for doing Windows containers.
Some quick benefits.
Being agile is one.
Being able to spin these
up, shut them down,
rapid development, that's essential.
Cost-wise, we do see customers save
about 60% under EC2 costs,
roughly about 68% on their storage costs
and reducing your management overhead.
If you are something like, you know,
EKS and orchestrator, you know,
patching, getting them back,
getting them up, failovers, all this,
it's a much, much simpler
management as well.
When we're choosing these,
there are some considerations
to be brought up.
For example, this is 2025.
As we go into 2026, if I
have a new application today
and it's going to use cross-platform.net,
I'm gonna choose Linux, let's be honest.
It's just going to be modern.
However, for Windows applications,
they're a little bit beefier,
so you're going to start off immediately
with a three-gig image,
which means that the
host has to be larger.
So cost is an issue.
The size of that image is also an issue.
Only certain applications
can be used as well
to be containerized.
And we'll dive into what
some of those applications
can be as well.
We do see, across the financial industry,
healthcare industry,
a lot of use cases in AWS
for customers taking their applications
on Windows containers.
And the types of applications
that we do recommend to take
would be your ASP.NET,
WCF or Windows Services Applications,
and finally, Console Applications.
Anything that requires a full GUI,
absolutely skip that one for right now,
these would be your best bet.
If it runs on Windows Server today,
there's a pretty good chance
that you can containerize
that application.
Now, to get started altogether with this,
you only need five items.
The first item you need
is your Dockerfile.
That's your blueprint
for your application.
It has everything in there.
The second item here is
your Proprietary Base Image.
Typically, that's your
Windows Server core image
that you can just pull
down from Microsoft.
Third item is your registry
to store your images.
In this case we'll say ECR.
Fourth, you need your host
for worker nodes and so on,
which would be EKS.
And finally, you need your orchestrator.
For just failovers, bringing these up,
spinning down all of that,
again, EKS is your friend here.
So just these five simple items,
you are actually off and
running with containers.
Now, one thing that you can do as well
is to speed up the deployment
from pulling the actual image
to actually starting that off as well,
is using what we do is EC2
Image Builder cache strategy.
And how this works is basically,
you create a custom AMI.
And within that you bake
in all the components to it
through the Image Builder.
And we're gonna fly through this.
There is a blog that
explains this much deeper
and you can Google this up online.
But essentially, by doing this,
it does all the work for you upfront.
So then when you go to launch this,
it actually launches about 65% faster
than without a caching strategy.
And just so you can see this,
I've got two screenshots here.
The top one is using
basically a vanilla.net,
ASP.net application.
It is using the image cache strategy.
And the advantage of
that is, as you can see,
pull to pull is about 54 seconds.
On the bottom you see two arrows there,
we have a pull and then
finally it's pulled
and up and working and started.
It takes 7x longer.
So you can see the image cache strategy
does absolutely benefit
and gets that launched
much quicker for you.
I'd mentioned back in 2023, Karpenter,
AWS does support Karpenter.
It's highly recommended,
works with the kube-scheduler
so it automatically spins
up nodes as is needed.
There'll be cost-effective,
works with the compute provider,
absolutely something that should be used
when you are running Windows containers.
This week, you're probably
hearing a lot about
AWS Transform.
We're not going to dive too much into it,
but during your modernization journey,
what you will be considering doing
is also modernizing the code afterwards.
The first step is to
get it into a container.
That way you can modernize
without having to do any code adjustments.
The follow up to this would be to use
AWS Transform for .NET,
point that at your application
and it generally will
increase the conversion time,
about 4x is what we're seeing
back from customers today.
Like I mentioned, if you want
to learn more about Transform
pop by the Expo Center, go
down by the Amazon booths,
all of them have either VMware
and other items that
they'll discuss there,
code analysis, everything
like that for you.
And on that note,
I'm gonna pass you off to
the guys from Tipalti here.
Maya, Danny,
if you wanna take it away.
- Thank you.
- Perfect.
- Thank you, Aidan.
- Amazing.
Thank you, Aidan.
So Danny, tell us what
Tipalti is all about.
- Well, Tipalti is an
finance automation platform
powered by AI.
And it basically streamlines
all your CFO operations.
Anything from global payouts,
account payables, procurement,
tax compliance, treasury,
you name it, we've got it.
So it actually just makes
your life a lot easier.
Everything, all financial operations,
just make it life a lot better.
So we distinguish ourselves by combining,
sorry, sorry,
by combining a single suite platform
with the simplicity and all
the complexity you can imagine
just making simple.
- Amazing.
Now, let's talk about
the technical foundation.
Tell us about the application architecture
that started this journey.
- All right, so picture
the early Tipalti days.
A .NET 4.7 platform, sorry, framework,
and monolithic architecture
and a payment platform.
And all of that fun stuff
was actually hosted on EC2 instances,
which is like most monoliths are.
And our process was
actually multiple processes
running all these EC2 instances,
you know, fast to develop, reliable,
great match for a startup phase.
- Well, that's a good setup.
Early stage priorities are
all about speed and focus
while enterprise scale demand
something else entirely.
How did that initial success played out?
- It played out great.
So for initial phase it was wonderful.
Quick releases, stable
reliable in production,
it was really fun to work with.
But as you expand,
all these things kind of
hit a small bottleneck
and we quickly agreed its capabilities.
- So you started with a clean,
straightforward, monolith,
served you well at first.
What happened when Tipalti began to grow?
- When growth happens, it happens fast.
And when it does,
you need more features, more resilience,
and pretty much a lot more of everything.
So our single process kind of just evolved
to multiple child processes
from a single parent.
And that's kind of
becoming a little complex
when all of them suddenly,
well, you need to run them,
they run on a schedule
and sometimes, you know,
they move out after 18 years.
- Well, that growth is pretty common.
I bet it'll do some serious
operational headaches.
- Definitely.
Headaches is just putting it lightly.
Debugging was just a nightmare.
Imagine just taking a single
process out of these hundreds
and just figuring out which
one was actually the culprit.
Meanwhile, we're still
running on EC2 capacity,
it was fixed and we had no scaling.
It was truly challenging.
- So you had your architecture complexity
and infrastructure limitations.
When did it start impacting the business?
- The turning point was when
our hundreds and thousands
of transaction volume just
exploded into millions.
Our systems just struggled to keep up.
I mean, we had frequent
crashes, delayed payments,
slow performance, and most
of all, angry engineers.
That's not fun, guys.
- Well, that's what every
scaling company dreads,
that the architecture that
powered the initial success
start holding it back.
So what Tipalti experienced isn't unique.
We see in the companies that
started as a monolithic,
a few common pain points.
Well, the first is your application
was built for a fixed world.
You buy a server, you run
your application on it,
simple, predictable until it isn't.
You are overprovision
just to handle peak loads.
And you are wasting resources
the rest of the time.
And if you have any capacity spike,
there's no elasticity,
your application simply
wasn't made for it.
And then there's the day-to-day.
Your deployment that should take minutes,
stretch into hours,
and you are often flying blind.
Troubleshooting feels
more like a detective work
than engineering.
And then there's the
point when the monoliths
becomes the bottleneck.
Release cycles slow to a crawl.
Every component in the
system is intertwined
and every bug can repel
through the entire system.
If you try to adopt modern
DevOps practices like CI/CD,
it becomes an uphill battle.
The architecture is not built for it.
And what really hurts
is the business level.
The architecture that
fueled your initial success
still simply wasn't built for it.
So you are facing with two choices,
spend years rewriting or
live with the constraint.
So Danny, what option did
you consider at Tipalti
and how did you arrive to your solution?
- We decided that containerization
was the right way to go.
But then we had a choice,
was it ECS or EKS?
Well, we decided on an EKS
because it felt a lot more natural for us
and we are already heavily invested in it
using our Linux workloads.
So it was great for us.
And then also, it addressed
the scalability challenge
far better.
And finally, we needed machine access
because, well, let's face
it, sometimes Windows,
you need to understand the
intricates of the stuff.
So we had that, we needed that access.
And finally, Windows and Kubernetes
is kind of the uncharted territory,
so that was fun to go with.
- Where did the confidence come from?
- Absolutely, from our DevOps team.
Those guys were relentless.
They just tore it into that stuff
and they just really
remodeled the entire thing.
And also, you know, the container
ecosystem was very mature
so it helped out,
so it was great.
And we decided on a minimal risk approach.
We wanted to stay as close as we can
so we could focus on the application
instead of the platform.
So EKS was naturally
the perfect fit for us.
- So basically,
when you're ready to containerize
your Windows application,
you get to a fork in the road,
do you go with Amazon Elastic
Kubernetes Service, EKS,
or Amazon Elastic Container Service, ECS?
Let me just go over both
and explain what each offers
so you will know why
Tipalti made their choice.
So let's start with Amazon ECS.
Think of it as AWS knows best approach.
We've taken hard one lesson
from running containers
at massive scale and
baked everything right
into the service.
And the good thing is that
you don't have to become
an orchestration specialist overnight.
ECS is opinionated in the best way
and it's relevant for team
who wants to focus more
on the application and
less on the infrastructure.
Now, EKS tells a different story.
This is for team who want the full power
of Kubernetes experience
or maybe for teams like Tipalti
who were already running
Kubernetes on other workloads.
You are getting the same
experience everywhere.
So how do you choose?
Basically it comes down to your team's DNA
and where you want to spend your energy.
ECS focus on the application
and less on the infrastructure
while EKS offers you that
Kubernetes flexibility
or when your standardizing
across environment
is part of your strategy.
And the good thing is
that both are 100% ready
for Windows production workloads.
So the question is not
which one works better,
it's which one fits your team's strategy.
So it comes down to
control versus simplicity.
And Tipalti chose
because of their
extensive DevOps expertise
and their need for a deep
debugging of their environment.
Now, when it comes to
.NET application on AWS,
this flowchart is here to
help make the decision.
How do we move?
So it's kind of a prescriptive
and it requires some
investigation and deep dive,
but eventually, there
are three migration path
corresponding to those paths.
So the first one is rehost, okay?
It's simply moving your application as is
to traditional servers
like Amazon EC2 instances.
The second, which is replatform,
is making some changes to your application
to accommodate the underlying
platform compute changes,
like moving to run on Windows containers.
And the third one is refactor,
which is re-architecting your application.
This pattern help you to
use cloud native solutions
such as serverless
or porting your .NET framework application
to cross-platform.net and
run on Linux container.
And finally, this is
the path Tipalti chose,
they were already running
on Amazon EC2 instances
and they decided not to spend years
rewriting their code base
and to move to run on Windows containers.
Now, Danny, let's dive
into the nuts and bolts.
Walk us through what it took
to get your Windows
container running on EKS.
- So first of all, we
read every single AWS dock
that mentioned Windows and
Kubernetes in the same breath.
And we found out there are
a couple of key nuances
that you have to set up
right from the start.
Now if you don't do that,
you're probably not gonna have
a smooth sailing in the process.
- Okay, so once you had
the lay of the land,
what were those setup steps?
- Well, the first one is
actually setting up your VPC CNI.
And that's the actual
component that's responsible
to handing out IP addresses to your pods
and tying it to your VPC.
So we had to tweak it with
the right flag as you can see.
And it was very straightforward.
However, unlike Linux nodes,
Windows nodes don't run the AWS node pod
that actually does the tying
for your IP address to your VPC.
That actually happens internally.
And that's a fact we had
to really pay attention to
going later on.
Next, we had to tweak in
the AWS IAM permissions
specifically for Windows nodes.
It has a small addition to Linux nodes,
so we had to tweak that as well.
And that actually used to
live in AWS auth config,
which is now conveniently
replaced with access entries.
- Okay, so once the
foundation was in place,
how did you decide which Windows container
or which Windows version
or which container setup you want to use?
- We decided to stay as
close to home as we could,
so we decided with Windows
containers Server Core 2019
running on Windows Server
2019 server nodes, right?
Very identical, very close to home.
At some point we actually tried to match
the OS build of Windows,
but that proved to be very, very tricky,
so we stuck to LTSC versions
and it was very, very
simple for us to do that.
- Okay, so that's a pragmatic approach,
especially for business
critical workloads.
So compatibility can make
or break a deployment.
So what drove this level of cautions?
- It was about risk reduction.
So this is a payment platform,
zero tolerance for downtime
or any interruption.
So we wanted to stay
as close and identical
to something we already knew was running.
And by moving to the
same setup on Kubernetes,
we were actually able to reduce
operating system overheads.
So it played out well for us.
But it's only part of the trick.
Sometimes you have to pay attention
to what Windows images
you're gonna choose.
- You are right.
So Microsoft offers four
container base images,
which each one exposing
different windows API set,
and this is what influence on
the final container image size
and on this footprint.
So let's start with the
minimalistical dream, Nano Server.
This image expose just enough Windows API
to run a cross-platform.net
or modern open-source frameworks.
So it's excellent for
building sidecar containers
or when every megabyte
matters in your deployment,
it's lean, it's fast,
and it gets the job done.
The next is a Server Core
and there's the reason
this is the crowd favorite.
This one strikes the sweet spot
between efficiency and functionality.
It expose those Windows API sets
that support .NET framework
and those bread and butter
Windows Server features like IIS,
and it covers the majority of
enterprise application needs
without going overboard.
Well, the next one is Server.
It's a little smaller than
the full Windows image,
but don't let that fool you.
It packs the complete Windows API set.
It makes it perfect for applications
needing to run DirectX
graphic capabilities.
Like having a compact car
with a surprisingly powerful
engine under the hood.
And the last one, the
heavyweight champion,
is the full Windows image.
It expose every single
Windows API you can think of.
It's massive,
but if you need to run
graphic-intensive application
or cutting edge machine
learning framework,
this is your go-to.
So when you come to choose,
you need to consider everything
you bring along with you,
those ODBC driver your application calls
or those specific APIs you need to run.
If you go too small, your
application won't run.
And if you go too big,
you're hauling around unnecessary weight,
it will slow down your deployments.
So Danny, at this point,
your EKS was configured
and ready and what were the next steps?
- Well, the first step is encountering
our significant first blocker.
- Oh, okay, let's talk
about those blockers.
- That's really fun stuff, you know?
So the first challenge was about logging.
But, you know, launching a container
is usually the easy part,
and debugging what's
misbehaving is actually,
well, the most interesting
part about containers.
So picture this that you're running on,
sorry,
picture this that you're
running on an EC2 machine,
and what you'd usually
use is an XML format,
which is standard, reliable,
and you'd install a Fluent Bit engine
and you'd get those logs right
into your logging system,
which is very easy and very fun to do.
But when you go into Kubernetes, Windows
and you need JSON format,
all that goes out the window.
That's not gonna work that easy.
So what you're actually gonna do
is you're faced with a couple of choices.
Do you bake the agent into the Dockerfile?
Do you run a sidecar?
Do you look for a vendor
to solve it for you?
Or do you rewrite the
application completely?
Just for the logs, right?
- So,
here's where Windows containers
throw you a curve ball
that sometimes catches teams off-guard.
In the Linux world, logging
is beautifully simple.
Your application, your
containerized application
dumps everything to standard out,
the container runtime catches it,
and boom, you have logs flying.
It works every time.
Now, in the Windows world,
pods don't generate standard
out by default, okay?
And here comes a solutions
that's called Log Monitor.
Think of it as a universal translator
for your Windows login.
It formats everything,
from ETW, from your Windows Event log
and your application-specific logs.
And it formats everything
and pipes it to standard out,
something that Linux does by default.
It's like a bridge between the two worlds.
So how to set up it, it's pretty simple.
You take Log Monitor,
you integrate it into your
Windows AMI during the build,
you configure your log
specification as part of,
in your pod,
you build,
you deploy a log forwarder,
like a Fluent Bit
and configure it to
send everything onwards,
to hopefully, CloudWatch.
So,
as Danny mentioned,
I will share something from experience.
So formatting is very important.
Always log in
structure format like JSON or CSLOG
because you will be very grateful
if you're debugging at 2:00 AM
and you have logs that you can pass.
And second thing, less is more
when it comes to verbosity,
keep it quiet unless you
are actively debugging.
Important event can get lost in the noise.
So this is the technical.
How did it actually played out?
- [Danny] Well, we started
off with Log Monitor,
just as you mentioned.
And once we plugged it
in, we actually saw logs.
It was great.
Worked really well.
So we actually were able to
see our logs within our system
and played out pretty well.
And it actually confirmed for us,
we were able to see a Windows container
with a legacy application,
and logs flowing through our system.
It was good.
- [Maya] So seeing the process live logic
was kind of pressing, I'm guessing.
So did Log Monitor stay
in your configuration
for a long time?
- Initially it did, until it didn't.
Because we actually found
out that Log Monitor
introduced some unwanted
baggage and overhead.
It kind of made the
application crash sometimes,
it crashed on its own.
It wasn't very fun to
hear and look, of course.
And one of the things about it
is when you hook one process into another,
it's bound to have some
mysterious activity in it.
So it's not very effective.
So what we actually did,
we modified our application
logging configuration
to log directly to standard out
and actually just solve
the problem for us.
And once we did that,
we had logging, flowing into
our centralized logging system
and the first challenge was
just marked as completed.
So that was good to go.
- So once this hurdle was behind you,
what came next in the road
to production readiness?
- Our next challenge was
a completely different set
of difficulties,
something completely unexpected.
So we were testing various
application versions,
it was great,
until we stumbled upon
something really, really nasty.
I mean,
what happened was we would
roll out a new version
and we'd saw pod getting
stuck in terminating state
for quite a long time,
I mean, like five minutes or something,
depending on your configuration,
but they were just stuck there
instead of just terminating
process as they should.
- So first of all,
that sounds very frustrating.
Can you tell me what was
happening under the hood?
- Yes.
So we actually suspected something
between the kubelet and containerd.
So in a nutshell, once
you shut down a container,
Kubelet actually sends that
signal to the container,
executes any preStop hooks along the way,
and then a container actually shuts down
and reports back to kubelet
that it's gracefully shut down
having fun.
But actually, for us, it
wasn't really happening
because you see in Linux
you have the SIGTERM
and in Windows you have
something different,
an equivalent of that,
which at that point wasn't
really propagating properly,
so we had to really
investigate to understand
what was going on.
- So Kubernetes was doing its job,
but the signal was not what
the application was expecting?
- Yes, so our application
was actually coded
to handle that specific
Windows event for shutdown
just fine.
But Kubernetes tried to send that signal
and nothing was happening.
So we figured along those lines
that something was going on.
So that stuck period,
were actually Kubernetes
force killing the pod
using the graceful termination period.
So it was stopping, but not gracefully.
Very brutally, in fact.
- So,
what were you trying to do
to pinpoint the root cause?
- Well, we dug in, well you have to.
So we actually found that it
was a bug in the containerd.
At the time, AWS was running
two different versions
for AWS Linux and for Windows.
And for Windows, they
were running Version 166.
And apparently in that version
a single propagation for
Windows was not supported,
so that's why it wasn't working.
- Okay so,
this is where Windows
diverse from Linux again.
As Danny said, Kubernetes
sends a SIGTERM signal
the Windows runtime translate
to something called control shutdown,
which is the Windows native event.
If your Windows application
receives the event,
it will just behave normally
and shut down the application.
But the translation is very crucial
because Windows applications
are built to respond only
to control shutdown
event and not to SIGTERM.
So the container runtime acts as a bridge
between the Kubernetes
world and the Windows world.
So how did you work with
AWS to handle the gap?
- Well, we reached out AWS through GitHub,
so it was a great collaboration.
We opened an issue and somebody replied.
Very straightforward.
It was very quick to do.
And they confirmed that a later
release fixing that issue,
just upgrading a version
was coming later that year.
But unfortunately for us,
you know, we can't wait.
We have to solve these things
right here and right now.
- So you found a workaround?
- Of course, we did.
What we did, we relied on
Kubernetes native features.
We introduced the lifecycle
hooks we mentioned earlier,
and we tuned in our
graceful termination period.
So we had more control
over when our application
was shutting down and
how it was shutting down.
So it played out well for us.
So all we had to do was just sit back
and wait till AWS released
the newer containerd version
and we're set to go.
- Okay.
So once that was behind you
and everything was up and running,
how did you validate that
the containerd version
was behaving as expected?
- We decided on the ultimate
head-to-head battle.
So we compared our EC2 environment
to our Kubernetes environment.
So they were running side by side,
same configuration, same environment.
And they were both plugged
into the same RabbitMQ.
And what we saw was a
mysterious new client
just consuming these messages,
making our developers actually
coming over and saying,
what is this new container doing?
What is this new agent that's
consuming our messages?
And, of course,
it was our Windows pod
just pulling its own way.
- So another thing very
satisfying to watch.
- Definitely.
Finally we could actually
see our container,
Windows container working properly
on real business live logic
and it was really great to see.
So what we did next, we
bullet-proofed everything.
We touched performance,
we touched the baseline,
we continued with testing,
and then we're very eager
to start the next phase.
- Okay, so now you are ready
to test the core premise
of cloud native
transformation, scalability?
- Definitely.
This is the moment we've
been waiting for completely
because we wanted to test scalability.
So what we did,
we, of course, plugged in our Windows pods
and we tuned them to listen
to messages on RabbitMQ
using Kee-da or KEDA as you prefer.
And because we wanted to actually scale
based on amount of work to
be done instead of, you know,
just server work,
server load, I'm sorry, CPU or memory,
which is classic but not enough.
Well, not today anyway.
And finally, the other half of
the battle is infrastructure.
You can't scale application
if your infrastructure doesn't support it.
And since we were on Kubernetes
and we're already using Karpenter,
all we had to do was
just extend it, right?
Just another CRD.
- So what kind of result did you see
when you tested the scalability?
- A great kind of
results, scaling results.
We were actually able to see our pods
and our Windows nodes scaling
up and down very seamlessly
and efficiently.
So that was a really great
turning point for us.
We enjoyed that spectacle.
- Okay so,
this is a huge shift from the old model.
So beyond the scalability itself,
what other improvements did you notice?
- We noticed that by running the EC2
and the Kubernetes
equivalent side by side,
we actually got a 50% improvement boost.
That was completely unexpected.
It wasn't just scaling better,
it was just actually more
efficient in how it was working.
- And from operational perspective?
- That was a real game-changer,
because at that point,
instead of just debugging
hundreds of processes,
we had a single pod with its own process
and we could see logs, traces, metrics,
were just beautiful, super
simple, very straightforward.
- So,
Karpenter is AWS native,
it understands things like spot
pricing and EC2 commitments.
So it can help you not just
scale up, also to scale down,
to consolidate workloads,
and shut down nodes.
So,
if we're speaking of costs,
let's talk about it,
because I think this is
something that will interest
a lot of people.
Going to a full-blown Kubernetes cluster,
running Windows must have
its financial trade-offs.
- Definitely.
I'll be honest about it,
because our infrastructure
and our cost kind of
spiked up a little bit,
but not by much, you know,
on a good note.
But it was actually very, very worth it.
- How did you justify
such additional costs?
- Well, the operations
actually weigh out the spend.
We got a 50% boost,
we got scalability and ease of deployment.
I mean, all these things
when you factor in together,
I mean they,
well, they kind of justify
this extra spend, right?
So while our server bill
actually did spike a little bit,
factoring our total cost,
all the pain and suffering
we've kind of alleviated
from our developers and
customers was just worth it.
- Still,
every smart company looks for
optimization opportunities.
What strategies are you exploring,
you know, to keep the cost in check?
- Well, we tried spot instances,
but unfortunately our application
couldn't handle the shutdown
event for two minutes
with a notice for spot instances.
So that was out the window.
Instead, we relied on savings
plans and reserved instances.
For right-sizing, we used
EC2 Compute Optimizer.
And finally, we traced our resource usage
using AWS Container Insights
to rightsize our actual pod usage.
And as you know, the
cost-efficiency battle
and the performance battle never ends.
It's an ongoing session.
- You are right,
it never ends.
Just another insight.
It's very important to use cost
explore there is a feature,
there is an option to
enable a cost allocation,
split cost allocation
data, also known as CAD.
And you can also leverage
cloud intelligent dashboards
to monitor your container costs.
You can set up budgets,
you can set up alerts to let you know
if you have a cost spike unexpectedly.
And as Danny said,
the key insight is that cost
optimization is a journey.
It's not a one-time activity
and you need to always have
it in the back of your mind.
So what's the long-term impact?
- Overall, it's an absolute win.
We were able to cut down
on manual operations,
on response times and debugging,
and best of all,
we're actually able to
eliminate the infrastructure
and bottleneck we had for scalability.
And that kind of thing is priceless
no matter how you try to go around it.
- Okay so,
now everything is stable again.
What area did you focus on improving next?
- We decided to focus on two key areas.
One of them being the node creation time
and the image pull duration.
And if you break it down,
then node provisioning actually
takes around seven minutes
from EC2 creation to joining
the Kubernetes cluster.
And images were actually about
four minutes just to pull.
- Okay so,
let's focus on the nodes first.
Seven minutes is noticeable.
- Yeah.
So definitely, noticeable.
And we dug in,
and we saw, of course,
that EBS configuration
was actually the culprit
for the entire thing.
So as you know, the baseline
when you create an EC2 machine,
you get 125 megabytes of
throughput with IOPS around 3000.
That's great for general workloads,
normal EC2 machines running, that's fine.
But when you're talking about Windows
and you want to go
faster, that's not enough,
because Windows needs
more bootstrapping time
and processing.
So we did the natural thing.
We doubled all the values.
And actually it shaved off
around a minute, even more.
So from seven minutes we cut down to six
and sometimes even lower than that.
And we tried going different directions
and trying to explore different values.
But that was in vain,
unless you're willing
to go the extra spend
and try using io1 volumes, which are,
well, you know, very
expensive and blazing fast.
- Okay, so that's a fair
trade-off eventually.
And the second bottleneck,
the container images,
I imagined that around four
gigabyte of container image
is not exactly?
- No.
So our actual image containers,
they wait around four and a half
when you take in the baseline image
and the application itself.
So it turned out to be around 4.5.
And when you start pulling it out
then it kind of takes a long time.
And if you compare it to
Linux then it's massive,
four and a half gigs over to what,
a hundred megs on a Linux machine.
That's fairly massive.
- So what did you do?
Did you change the structure
or was it something from the AWS side?
- Actually, it was a bit of both.
We noticed that at some point AWS started
pre loading base images onto
their EKS-optimized AMIs.
So after a few AMI version changes,
we noticed it was a quiet change
and it dropped down from four
minutes to around 50 seconds.
It was great.
Yeah, pretty much,
but we were not satisfied.
We introduced an internal image registry.
And by doing so,
we were actually able to
cut down from 50 seconds
to 20 seconds, and it's just very fast.
- That's a very dramatic improvement.
So,
what kind of overall impact
the optimization had?
- By combining both results,
we were able to slash the
times from 11, 11 1/2 minutes
to around six, sometimes even less,
6:30 was being the average.
And it actually made all our deployments
feel very responsive, very snappy.
So it was one of those moments
when you invest all this time fine tuning
and actually does pay off.
- Okay.
So things were smooth by then, right?
Production was stable?
- At that point, yeah,
we were pretty stable.
We were running with four Windows nodes,
scaling up and down with 35 Windows pods,
with being more services added every day,
it was great to look at.
And we're actually still running with 50%
and improved performance boost
and our deployments are
around six and a half minutes.
But the best of all,
the dramatic reduction
in incident response time
and all the incidents was just
blowing us out of the water.
- Okay.
And what about your team's
operations day to day?
- Well, they shifted from
actually firefighting all the time
to, you know, innovating,
writing new features,
rewriting, refactoring
even a bit of the code.
- Oh nice.
But it wasn't the end, right?
- No.
Unfortunately, that was not the end.
We actually, well,
it was a bad ending I have to say.
So at this point,
we're after the containerd saga,
it was very difficult time
and then we were finally kind of stable.
But at some point,
we noticed that when we
started rolling new versions,
the pods really refused to die.
You try to force delete
them, they'd still be there.
No termination grace
period that could help.
Nothing. They were just stuck there.
At some point, we start
calling 'em zombies.
- I don't know what about you,
but I don't like zombies, okay?
So,
I'm guessing it was very frustrating.
How do you begin to hunt it down?
- Well, we spent six weeks debugging
with AWS Support Team on this.
We'd every time get a new theory,
understand, see if it
can work, test it out,
no, of course not,
and we're just really pulling
our hair at this point.
So we're just hunting it
down and nothing worked.
- So six weeks to hunt is a long time.
What did the investigation
finally turn up?
- Well actually, it was
a critical regression bug
at the platform level.
It was one of those Windows services,
the host networking service,
which is actually
responsible for networking
that we have zero visibility into.
- So a black box bug?
- Yes, definitely a black box bug.
- So can you walk me through
the technical details
of what was actually happening?
- Yes, it turned out to be a nasty,
really nasty race condition.
when one pod was starting
and one was actually shutting down,
it was causing the networking component
to actually create two dual endpoints.
So at one point,
you had a living pod and a dead pod,
kind of, you know,
Schrodinger's pods if you say.
And that was kind of very
difficult to understand
how it was working,
but we were able to
understand and find it.
- Okay so,
what did the AWS do?
- Well, as we were working with AWS,
they decided to, of course,
go into the networking components,
they tore 'em out completely
and traced the bug to a
recent platform change.
And they fixed it at the AMI level
and they of course coordinate with us.
- Okay so,
but a platform level fix is not
something that is immediate.
It takes time.
So how did you,
you know,
how did you do in the meantime?
What did you,
when you waited for the
actual AMI to be released?
- [Danny] We got a little creative.
So we were using Karpenter
feature to introduce a TTL,
time to live, on our nodes.
So we kind of paved over the problem
by refreshing the nodes every three hours,
meant clearing the bad
networking state entirely.
And we also introduced some
manual and automated procedures,
you know, to exercise those demons.
And finally, we added alerts
just to catch them just enough
or even before it actually happens.
So we could actually tell
when's it gonna happen.
- [Maya] Okay.
And the final resolution,
did AMI do the trick?
- [Danny] Definitely.
When AWS released that AMI fixed,
we immediately implemented
it and it fixed everything.
So we were actually back
to reliable production,
everything was stable,
smooth sailing from then.
- [Maya] Okay.
- And, you know,
it was also a challenging
time for us as well.
We were working hard with
AWS and it kind of, you know,
strengthened our partnership deeper.
- That's always good to hear.
So let's zoom out for a minute.
Can you tell me, after all this work,
what did this transformation
actually achieve for Tipalti?
- Yes.
So definitely our results,
we had a 50% performance boost
constantly across the board.
When comparing EC2 to Kubernetes,
our scalability just changed completely.
From six hours from creating
a machine and installing
and everything to just a
pod running everything.
It meant from six hours to six minutes.
That's incredible on its own.
And also just the installation
and running the pod in the servers itself,
I'm sorry, from running on
four-minute installation
to just 30 seconds on a
(indistinct) deployment.
That's a massive improvement for us.
- And how did life change for the team?
- For the better, of course.
So we went from 12-hour
debugging sessions to just two
because we had clear
observable telemetry for logs,
traces, and metrics from
a single pod process
instead of just hundreds of millions
of multiple sub-processes.
- Okay, and from the business side?
- Well, we achieved something
that was pretty impossible
for us early on.
We had no horizontal scaling
and we actually were able to solve that
using this transition.
So the business impact was
just incredible for us.
And we employed, of course,
it opened the door, sorry,
it opened the door for
many modern dose practices
so we can just employ them
and continue innovating our procedures.
- Okay, and when you look
back on those journeys,
zombie pods and all,
what are the key lessons
learned you'll share with people
thinking about similar transformation?
- Well, I'll break it
down into a few key areas
that we actually learned the hard way.
So on a technical perspective,
you gotta start with small changes, okay?
You have to test it out first.
Understand if you can do that.
And by doing so,
you can preserve your
existing .NET framework
and get modern benefits all the time.
And kind of, you know, when
you're working with Windows,
just expect some unexpected things,
it's kind of a cliche to say.
But, you know, Windows is
always behaving like it does.
And from operations perspective,
engage AWS proactively.
It's saved us so much time
if we would've done that a lot on earlier.
And most of all, document everything.
We documented every single process
and every single execution that we did
just so we have enough
information to go on.
Strategically, incremental
monetization works.
It works 100% of the time.
You don't need to rewrite
your application from scratch,
you can just start small.
And from a crisis management point,
the Schrodinger's pods actually taught us
to be a lot more proactive.
And by doing so,
we're actually able to
overcome all these issues
that we faced.
So comprehensive monitoring
definitely is a must,
especially for these types of things.
And you should also have
mitigation strategies.
Don't just blindly go into something.
You have to think some sort of way
for the unexpected issues.
- So,
there are four critical factors
that usually contribute to
a successful transformation.
So the first one is executive support.
And I don't just mean someone
writing off on the check.
Executive support means management.
Understanding that this is
not just an IT project, okay?
It's a business transformation.
And one of the biggest
transformation killers
is organizational silos.
Solutions that works on
perfectly in isolation,
often fail in organizational reality.
So it's very important to
create the transformation teams
with developers, operations, security,
business stakeholders,
people who had a real
decision-making authority.
And I'm guessing that if
you want to containerize,
you want to do it yesterday,
but this is not a race.
It's like you don't want to
migrate during peak hours.
You need to take it easy
to start with non-critical workloads,
learn from experience,
live enough time for
testing, for troubleshooting,
and for the unexpected.
And last,
container technology is always evolving.
Successful teams build
learning into their DNA.
Not just initial training,
but an ongoing education
program, feedback loops,
best teams leverage support proactively,
using expertise to optimize architecture
and always stay ahead of best practices,
not just fix problems.
And now, Danny,
what's next for Tipalti?
- Well, the improvement game never stops.
So we're gonna continue exploring
how can we make everything much faster
from node provisioning to image pulls,
because we want to be as close
to Linux speed as possible.
Next, we're gonna be working
on more cost optimizations
because, you know, like I
mentioned, this never ends,
and you wanna save as much as you can
so we're gonna be heading
that direction as well.
We're also gonna be tuning in better
for our scaling policies.
So gonna be better scaling for
us as well, more proactive.
And all this endeavor actually
created a great foundation
for our microservices,
so we can port legacy
applications onto microservices
without a pressure of a complete rewrite.
- And what about your
broader technology strategy?
- Well, GitOps.
GitOps is the best.
So what we're gonna do
is we're gonna implement
more GitOps workflows.
And well, by doing so,
it can actually work with better
and more modern DevOps
applications and practices.
So that's not gonna end anytime soon.
- Okay.
So,
let me just say that,
that's a great example
what Tipalti did that
a successful transformation
can enable broader modernization effort.
The containerization is not the end goal,
but it helps set the foundations
on continuous modernization.
And that's the real
value of this approach.
If you want to continue your
containerization journey,
there are some resources
we put here to help,
you have the Windows Containers
on AWS Immersion Day,
Best Practices for Windows on Amazon EKS,
and check out Windows
Container in Kubernetes.
Take a picture, scan the
QR and go check it out.
And in addition,
beyond that,
if you don't know, we
have AWS Skill Builder,
which is your gateway to mastering
all things AWS cloud technology.
There are over a thousand
free, self-pacing,
expert-led courses.
You can follow guided journeys
or just jump directly to the
topics that interest you.
And with that,
thank you very much for being here today.
Feel free to reach out and stay tuned,
because the blog post on this
journey is in the making.
(audience applauding)
- [Danny] Thank you.
- [Maya] Thank you.